marylène iapichino alors vous connaissez
bien le club des scream de trappes un
corps vous y avez découvert leur
nouvelle discipline on en parlait
justement lancé en septembre le sabre
laser
oui michael il ya bien longtemps et aux
états unis la pratique a commencé un
long voyage jusqu'en france cette
discipline à effectuer car septembre
elle s'est installée officiellement
devenue la quatrième la 4e armes de
l'escrim le sabre laser et qui a reconnu
par la fédération française d'escrimé
il est toujours en mouvement et l'avenir
de ce sport et même des compétitions
entre apprentis y mettre il existe on
s'est rapprochés assez rapidement fait
de la fédération qui avait les mêmes
objectifs que nous c'est-à-dire
sécuriser la pratique et faire en sorte
qu'il ya un vrai programme de mise en
place au niveau des animateurs des
éducateurs pour que les gens qui
encadrent le sabre laser le fassent de
manière correcte et au respect des lois
françaises au niveau du sport alors vous
allez parler comme maître yoda pendant
toute la chronique marylène michael vous
rassurer je me dois car je ne suis
qu'une padawan les sabres laser c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelle ont plusieurs
manières de pratiquer cet art martial
pour les grands fans de l'univers star
wars il ya la façon chorégraphié comme
vous le voyez sur ces images c'était un
combat en équipe lors d'un championnat
organisé par l'académie de sabre laser
de voisins-le-bretonneux pour les
sportifs il ya le combat à la touche
avec les règles établies de la ffe ici
aussi des compétitions officielles sont
organisés un point pour les mains et le
pommeau trois points pour les membres 5
points pour la tête et le torse pour les
bases guillaume du club de trappes m'a
tout expliqué pendant leurs
entraînements où ils sont accueillis
dans un gymnase des longs cours or
guillaume gete instructeur ici au club
de sabre laser vous allez me montrer un
peu quels sont les gestes principaux
alors en fait dans notre siège de combat
on a ce qu'on appelle un système d'armé
dire que pour qu'une touche soit valide
il faut que préalablement le combattant
est amené salam derrière lui donc c'est
plus visuel pour le public et ça permet
un arbitre acheté beaucoup plus facile
donc autre sens
fonctionnement je parle de sa chair ça
permet d'être beaucoup plus facilement
arbitrable donc la deuxième chose c'est
qu'au début d'une phrase armes phrase
armes c'est un échange complet jusqu'à
ce qu'une séparation des deux
combattants ce qu'on fait ce qu'on
appelle un arm et d'engagement c'est à
dire que la lame le pommeau et la main
doivent passer derrière
voilà donc au si on est éloigné l'un de
l'autre
la première frappe faut qu'on passe
derrière et une fois qu'on a commencé à
faire des échanges il a juste besoin de
faire ça d'accord ok donc une autre
chose c'est ce qu'on appelle la notion
de parade riposte on est on a une notion
de priorité chez nous hier que le
premier qui va faire son arme et
d'engagement l'autre la paroisse de
l'attaqué il est obligé de se mettre en
défense
à partir du moment où je vous attaquez
vous paraît c'est vous qui prenez la
priorité moi j'ai pas droit de vous
attaquer quatre fois de suite comme un
bourrin donc à partir je suis bloqué
s'avoue d'attaqué je vous bloque etc etc
c'est une notion un peu comme aucune
conquis une motion de renvoi très bien
je pense que compris on va c'est qu'ils
étaient on va essayer c'est parti alors
seigneur sith ou maître jedi michael on
pourra essayer le sabre laser j'en ai
choisi un bleu bien sûr je vous laisse
voir mon combat
c'est toujours compliqué nature
[Musique]
bon ça c'est pour moi c'est assez
sportif le sabre laser à elancourt c'est
une fois par semaine
si vous voulez tester vous pouvez juste
vous renseigner auprès du club et que la
force soit avec vous